notre sénat a à coeur de soutenir la
recherche universitaire sur le
bicamérisme sur l'institution
sénatoriale sur les collectivités
locales nous avons donc créé d'une part
le prix de thèse du sénat qui récompense
un travail achevé et permet de publier
la thèse primé aux éditions dalloz et
d'autre part la bourse de recherche du
sénat qui soutient jeune universitaire
de talent dans la thèse est en cours de
rédaction dans les deux cas en l'aidant
de jeunes universitaires méritants nous
manifestons l'intérêt que nous portons à
la recherche sur le parlement et
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics les
tests doivent porter sur le bicamérisme
sur l'institution sénatoriales où depuis
cette année sur les collectivités
locales les années passées par exemple
les thèses retenu porté sur le corps
législatif du directoire ou plus
récemment sur la transparence et la
déontologie du mandat parlementaire la
bourse de recherche du sénat apporte un
soutien financier aux doctorants dès la
première année de thèse en droit en
histoire ou en sciences politiques nous
souhaitons encourager les meilleurs
candidats
c'est pourquoi c'était des cumulables
dorénavant avec un contrat doctoral
conclu par un étudiant avec l'université
j'invite les étudiants de toutes les
universités de france a déposé leur
candidature à la bourse de recherche du
sénat ils trouveront toutes les
informations nécessaires sur le site du
sénat mes collègues sénateurs se
joignent à moi pour souhaiter bonne
chance aux futurs candidats et nous
attendons naturellement nombreux pour
concourir
[Musique]